Oh!
Is there...
Welcome back, Master!
Master!
Hello!
Oh no, where did my jazzy music go?
That's a little disappointing.
It was so... it felt like I was at a doctor's office.
I was kind of vibing to it.
Welcome, everybody, to The Sims!
Sorry, I had some... I had like a milk tea.
And it made my throat all...
So sorry.
My throat's a little bad today.
Or rather, my cough is bad today.
So sorry if I cough a lot.
This is the nostalgia music?
Really?
Let's see.
I...
I think I played The Sims 2 the most.
I would say.
Coughing baby.
Coughing baby!
I think I played The Sims 2 the most.
I had The Sims 1.
But my sister's friends kept stealing it.
So...
I only never got to play it very much.
So I'm very excited...
to play it today.
Now you found a version they can't steal.
Yeah!
Exactly!
So... oh my gosh.
I... I thought that this game would be more nostalgic for me.
Since I did play it a little bit.
But I was like, I don't think I recognize any of this music.
I think I really am so nostalgic for The Sims 2.
But that makes me want to try this even more then.
I only played The Sims 1, 2 and 3.
Are we on The Sims 5?
How many Sims are there now of the mainline series?
Eight!
Four!
Okay.
Literally one guide.
I'm so sorry I haven't been around since recovering from surgery.
I refuse to engage with MGS4.
Trust me, the series gets a lot cleaner if you ignore 4 and 5.
What are you...
What?
No!
MGS4 is great!
What?
No, yeah, no MGS4 slander here.
Wrong guy to tell that to.
I know!
Who do you think you're talking to?
Good morning, Minto.
Good morning, Minto!
But also, get better soon.
Disarray?
Thanks very much!
If you plan on playing older PC games in the future, I suggest looking at the PC gaming wiki.
Contains a bunch of fixes and tweaks to help old games run better on modern hardware.
I did not know that.
So glad you played The Simpsons 1.
The Simpsons, yes.
But...
Look, it's wanting me to click here.
Oh, learn how to play the game.
No, no, no, no.
What did I just press?
There's a new cab company in town.
Give them a call on your phone to go downtown.
Magic Town.
Studio Town.
Old Shuttle Town.
Old Town Shuttle.
Swizzle's Day.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Feeling down?
Vacation Town.
Help system.
Yeah, we'll keep it active.
Oh my gosh, look!
Wait.
It's a newspaper!
I can't delete it.
Oh my goodness, I just realized it went from like...
Okay, hold on.
It went from not widescreen to widescreen.
Hold on.
I have to rearrange everything now.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, widescreen town.
Okay, there we go.
Look at the paper!
We can't delete it though.
This music is so jazzy.
Should we build a home?
How do I activate the cheats?
How do I activate...
Hold on a second.
There we go.
Yes, we should.
Okay, okay, okay.
Slash Rosebud.
No, wait.
Control Shift C.
That sounds right.
Motherlode.
No!
What?
Is it too early?
Rosebud?
What's Rosebud?
What happened?
Control Shift C.
Nothing happened.
Rosebud.
I'm not getting any richer.
Build.
Where is my money anyway?
Let's zoom out.
Alright, let's make a funky house.
Oh, wow.
What is that?
I just bought it.
It was $25, but...
What is this?
Oh, I think this is a fence.
Oh!
What is this then?
How do I... Can I drag and hold?
Oh my gosh!
No.
No, it isn't.
It's just... Brandon!
Brandon!
This is not the time or place.
Anyway.
I wish I could get a description of what these are.
Fancy!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Wow, this is so fancy!
There is even barbed wire at the top.
Wait, hold on.
I want us to live on like a hill, right?
How do I demolish?
We are learning.
Hand tool.
Delete.
Nobody will be able to come inside.
Prison core?
No!
Look at the vines!
It's like a secret garden.
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
We are going to make this like...
I can't build houses in...
In Minecraft, but I think I can do it in The Sims just well.
Oh, they probably need a roof.
No!
They are hippie type.
I like your decor.
Thanks!
Alright.
Whoever is moving in here, they are going to have to...
Okay, this is how you get inside.
You dig a tunnel.
And you crawl underneath.
You can click and hold.
It wouldn't let me.
Hold on.
Maybe I'm not doing it right.
See?
I'm dragging it, but it's not working.
Maybe if I like...
Control?
No.
Alt?
Shift?
No.
I know there's got to be something.
Okay.
Wait.
The entrance.
You go in from underneath.
I told you it's a secret.
It's a secret entrance.
Secret garden.
Like Bugs Bunny.
I wish I could make it lower.
It's starting to turn into a moat.
And then...
Here...
Is the outlook point.
Wait.
I can't make a mountain!
What is this?
Nothing has descriptions.
I'm just... I'm blindly digging away.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Is this level?
This looks level.
This looks level, right?
No, it doesn't.
Not anymore.
Altitude is as high as possible.
That's what the tutorials are for.
We don't need...
Okay, let's...
We are in free mode.
We can just figure it out on our own.
We'll make a door right here.
And by door, anybody.
Everybody is welcome.
Hello?
Must be against a wall.
No!
This is a wall.
Neighbor be gone privacy fence.
Okay.
Eating...
Eating a bug bunny.
Wait, that bug...
Sorry.
Thanks for the five gifted.
What is this one?
I need a description.
The fact 20 column.
Okay, if I click and hold, we can see.
What is this?
The future.
None of these seem like...
Wall and fence tool.
None of these seem like inside house walls.
You know what I'm saying?
How am I supposed to live under these conditions?
These chungus.
That doesn't make any sense.
Logan, thank you for the five gifted.
Don't eyeball me.
There is only one normal wall?
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
Perfection.
What if we...
This works.
Okay.
Come on in.
We have an open door policy.
What?
Maybe I have to close the wall.
Yes.
Okay.
What other doors we got?
This one is fancier.
The inside will be...
Clown.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
This one I know we can click and drag.
Oh yeah.
Welcome to...
The zone.
Why is this one all messed up?
Hold on.
We got to fix the terrain everybody.
Is it...
Too high?
Now it's level.
This one needs to go up.
I think we're good.
What's this one?
No worries carpet.
It means no worries.
That will be the bathroom.
For the rest of your days.
I guess we have to lift...
Okay.
We have an entrance.
I guess we can...
Why isn't it normal?
Why can't I...
Is my depth perception so bad?
I'm confused.
Carpet in the bathroom?
We got it.
We're in tune with our...
With our...
With the 70s.
This one looks too high.
There we go.
Okay.
Up, up, up.
No, no, down.
No, no, no.
Down.
Up, up.
Gosh, being a contractor is so difficult.
I never knew that.
Hold on.
Can I get rid of some stuff?
We're committed to the bit.
Why isn't it normal?
Look at the width.
I would never think that.
I'm sampling the floors.
I like this.
Don't lie.
No, I'm not lying.
I'm not.
You're fine just the way you are.
I can't...
I can't make it taller.
Okay, you know what?
That's just gonna be a little quirk in the design, you know?
Avoid that spot right there.
Avoid that part right there.
Everything else is looking good.
I think we need to build walls.
Can you believe this is exactly how I used to play too?
It's like nothing has changed since when I was a kid.
This looks like my house on Sims Online.
Which was 100% real.
With MMO Sims?
What?
Oh no.
RIP.
I left for like 10 minutes.
Why does this look like an odd prison camp?
What?
Prison where?
What is this one called?
Oh, that's right.
This is the pile of logs.
I like this one.
Simbini's Tribute.
What is this?
Whoa!
I like it.
This can be what separates the bedrooms.
Nice.
Alright, we gotta put our...
Alright, we gotta furniture.
We gotta furn...
Oh, I can't put a roof?
Is it because of the steep part right here?
Hold on.
We gotta try and fix this part.
This is slow.
Is it too low?
Why won't it let me modify you?
I don't understand.
I messed up.
Try the 2 second icon.
Oh, the furniture.
Thank you.
In house, out house.
No, we're gonna give them the golden toilet.
In fact, I'm so rich.
They'll have 5 of them.
2...
3...
4...
5.
Okay.
What's this one?
Memorial.
Okay, nobody touches this one.
But it's a memorial toilet.
Which means it's probably important.
And we should put it behind walls.
How do I...
There we go.
Okay.
Like a grave?
Possibly.
It's kind of festive.
It is, right?
My hands and face are all red because of the cold.
Finish replacing multiple trunk lights in my car.
Can I order a warm drink?
Yes.
What would you like?
We have...
You can get...
We're out of everything.
Sorry.
You can make the ground level by using the 2nd tool in the terrain edit.
This?
The 2nd tool.
This one?
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, it worked!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Now we can put a roof...
Oh my gosh.
Look at that.
Wow.
Like the pyramids.
Fun fact, the Sims actually...
Games actually have lore.
And the Sims 3 is a prequel to the Sims 1 chronological...
No way.
Wait, I didn't know it was a prequel.
But I did know that there's like lore.
Like with the Goth family and stuff like that.
Okay, goodbye roof.
I don't want to look at you anymore.
It's so dark in there.
Today just felt like a fever dream, I've been sick the whole day.
No, Doomguy!
Go lay down.
What is this?
Oh, these are stairs.
Wow.
But we could also get...
These are stairs?
How does this work?
Oh, it's a teleporter.
Teleporter.
Okay, let's not get ahead of ourselves.
Let's focus on the first floor first.
Lighting.
Every room will have a hula lamp.
The lady lamp.
What's the lady of the house?
Barrel.
She's the light of our life.
It's like a little memorial.
Not memorial.
Can I get something to sleep?
I've been awake for over 24 hours.
Can you tell?
I couldn't tell.
Your MGS4 opinions make it clear.
Why is everybody sick?
Humans are so fragile.
Oh, it's a flamingo.
I thought it was like, you know, a neon lady.
Close enough.
This is our beach-themed bathroom.
Why are the lights on?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, I wanna keep it.
Okay, let's do the kitchen.
Kitchen.
Dining room.
Let's do appliances.
What's this?
Oh my gosh, do you never need to have a fridge if you just have a never-ending buffet?
Hot dog, indeed.
I don't know if I played this or Sims 2 when I was a baby.
I played The Sims, but then the Grim Reaper showed up and that terrified me.
Life hacks.
Who's Uncle Roger?
How long until death shows up?
No, I'm gonna keep my guys alive, I promise you.
We're gonna do our best.
They're gonna love this place.
They're gonna love it.
We're gonna have a full family.
Study.
We're gonna give them a computer.
Computer!
They're gonna have a computer.
They're gonna have the meet Marco.
Meow meow!
Thanks for the five gifts.
We're gonna have a little moose.
Nice.
Big ol' welcome rug.
No!
Wait, if I give them bear rugs, do you think that freaky bear will come?
I want that bear to show up.
I don't remember her name, but she's a bear that's like...
She like tiptoes in.
I don't know her name.
Can I thank everyone for wishing me well?
Of course.
Be well soon!
I wanna hire you for my house design.
Are you sure?
The red carpet into the bathroom is kind of peak, right?
What the heck is this?
I love having never ending money.
This is kind of great.
This makes a mess though, doesn't it?
We'll put it in the corner.
What is this?
A shower?
A porta potty.
Oh, you need one of those.
Lampy!
Thanks for the gifted!
What is that?
A garden lamp.
That's perfect, like... This place is kind of romantic, I'm not gonna lie.
Satellite dish.
Calling aliens.
Jack-o-lantern!
We need like...
Maybe three of these.
No!
Steve!
And this one is a awning.
Oh, that's perfect.
For him.
And...
Oh, a bed!
A bed, a bed, a bed, a bed.
Wait, where's the bed?
That's right, they don't need a kitchen.
They have it.
They have this.
What's a miscellaneous?
Electronics.
Oh, they can have a phone!
Yeah, that's important.
Spasmatronic go-go cage.
Dinner and a show?
I remember this thing.
This thing...
Gives you a robot, does it not?
This thing gives you a robot that will like do stuff?
Right!
Oh my gosh, I remember that thing.
I remember it.
I think we should have...
Actually, we do need a stove.
A stove.
But not because I want stuff to catch on fire or anything.
That would be ridiculous.
And a horrible thing to think.
I would never.
Currently I'm trying to redecorate my house but I'm unable to decide on a new theme.
Right now I'm between clowns and corn.
They remind me of Myoshi.
But I can't quite seem to pick one.
I love corn!
Is there a perfect family going to be Snake and Otacon with Sunny?
It's the neglected child!
No!
I'm not sick but I did slip and fracture my skull and nose!
I learned that the head bleeds a lot when...
No, Redcrest!
Redcrest!
Oh my gosh, feel better please.
I actually don't know what our family will be.
I haven't really thought about it.
Oh, we have a lot of space over here.
Hold on, we can move a couple things around.
We'll move this over here.
This can still be the living room with our show.
The show can go right there.
They can eat.
Wait, we'll give it a little bit more space.
I don't know who we should make.
I was thinking about making some of you guys though.
I was thinking of just picking out some names.
Mint Doki and Mata?
That is Matara's birthday.
Maybe we can...
What lucky fellow wants to be Matara's husband that she'll probably eat.
We'll see.
I'll figure something out.
We need some more lighting in here.
Not the outside.
Living room?
Oh, I think the lighting was here.
Oh, we've got the wallpaper.
A fireplace.
Romantic.
Wait, what's the difference?
Oh, wow.
We'll get a little pond.
And a pool.
Is that big enough?
Yeah, perfect.
Salt water, fresh water.
Salt water, pool, fresh water, pond.
Kid's fireplace and adult's fireplace.
And everybody...
Oh my gosh.
Tragic clown painting.
Doesn't this bring a clown or am I crazy?
We need some more decorations.
Oh, house tiger, house tiger.
Maybe like four of these.
Oh!
When the house is warm and the food is hot, the guinea pig cries, forget me not.
Alas, some sims may clean their own, only to forget a guinea pig's home.
Hungry and cold, a pig feels no love, thus breeds contempt for masters above.
Expect to play after many a night, who is surprised by the guinea pig bite.
Uncleaned, unloved, a pig's life means naught.
Like a child's plaything, it is simply forgot.
But warnings to all who turn a deaf ear, let the curse of the guinea pig always bring fear.
Didn't I say our bathroom was island themed?
Gotta have a marlin.
Oh, I thought this was JoJo's Bizarre Adventure!
You can kinda see it from like the...
From the small picture, right?
You can kinda see it.
Okay, we got some rugs, we need some plants.
Is this like a hanging plant?
Roses.
Sculptures.
That's ugly.
Do any of these feature undressed women?
Ew, my god!
This one's close enough.
They need something to look at when they're, you know, getting ready for bed.
They're like, I wanna be as relaxed as this character.
What else are we missing, guys?
What else are we missing before we get our family to move in here?
Oh, maybe a TV.
What is this?
Wall mounted.
Yeah, they want that.
Hold on.
A sofa, there we go.
No, this one.
Okay.
One window.
Oh, you're right!
Oh my gosh, this place is like a prison with no windows!
That's better.
What does that mean?
Oh my gosh, wow.
How rich
are your sims?
Like, crazy, crazy money.
Like, crazy money.
Look, they even have a bush outside.
What's this one?
Tumbleweed.
Oh, this is perfect.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, dang it.
Nice!
I wanna live in this clown townhouse.
It's not a clown house!
It's... It's actually...
It's actually really sought after for its...
It's... Think of like, the Hunger Games.
You know?
It's a clown prison.
No, it's not!
Look, what kind of clown prison would have a chandelier?
I think this is actually quite classy.
I would say.
Oh, neon.
Okay!
Do you guys think we have... Are missing anything else?
There's literally two windows!
What are you talking about?
There's no windows.
Arkham Asylum 6 edition.
Wallpaper.
I did!
I put wallpaper!
I put wallpaper.
Fine, you want other wallpaper?
You want a different design?
You want something else?
How... What was it?
Shift?
Ah, perfect.
There you go!
Oh, a bathtub.
Yeah, they do need to shower.
You're right, you're right.
That's an important thing.
Oh, a refrigerator.
Oh wait, we said a stove.
I forgot to do the stove.
Oh wow, an oven brick stove.
Okay, nice.
A dishwasher.
There we go.
And we'll give him even a coffee.
Do they need a sink?
Probably.
Probably need a sink.
What's this one?
Really rustic.
No, no.
Oh wow!
Oh, they also need to wash their hands in here.
Too much?
No.
No, no, no.
Let's give him... Oh wait, I did give him a bath!
What's this?
Does this not... Does the love tub not count?
Does that one not suit your taste?
Okay, hello.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Okay, we'll do this one.
Okay.
Okay, we have toilets, we have showers, we have sinks.
We have entertainment, we have sleep facilities.
We have toys.
We have...
Oxygen bar.
What the hell is that?
What is this?
Aquatic playhouse?
Oh my god!
Do you think I can reach that?
I need this.
What the heck is that?
I need to see that in motion.
Second floor?
Maybe...
My game just crashed.
No!
Did it save my house?
No, please.
Please, no.
Oh!
It hurts!
Make family first?
Okay, we can make a family first.
Wait, how do I leave?
How do I leave?
Oh, let's see.
Go, not quit.
Neighborhood.
Don't...
Don't cry me, don't take my money instead.
No!
Sims 4 crashed randomly too?
Sims 3 won't.
I actually really only... I didn't like the Sims...
You know what?
I think actually I really didn't like the Sims 4.
But I remember I think I also didn't like the Sims 3.
Freaking house gone, but not forgotten.
Okay, MataraCon.
Let's make Matara...
Oh my god, Matara.
Alright, she's an adult.
What the hell are these options?
Oh my god!
Why
does it look like that?
Oh my god.
Oh golly.
Is there... Oh my god.
Is there no customization in this game or...
I can't even change their hair colors or anything?
Nothing?
Oh wow, okay.
We'll just have to go for the closest thing we see.
Hot dog.
Rip freak house.
That nightmare mansion will live on in our hearts.
I was really happy about it!
I'm so sad.
Welcome to the Sims 1.
No!
I feel like...
No...
If you guys see one...
Pink hair?
Okay, this is our first option.
This... No.
This might be our second option.
She's really old.
I'm just looking for pink hair.
Anything with pink hair.
This is also a viable option.
It's like gotcha.
What if I just close my eyes?
These heads don't seem to match the body sometimes.
Okay, I think this is the only one we can choose.
She's the only one with pink hair.
Neat.
Kind of.
Outgoing max stat.
Active... We'll do like half.
Playful max stat.
Nothing else left.
Okay.
Bio for Mataracon.
Raiden would have loved that house.
Maybe after taking...
Oh wait, we forgot the body.
Gosh, these are all so sexy.
What the hell are these?
This one I think.
I feel like this one is basically her.
Space bug with no one to love.
She's...
She's making the best of her...
Our life.
Sorry.
My brain moves a little strangely.
The best of her life...
On Earth...
And...
Is desperate to eat...
Another husband.
It could be you!
Okay, done.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna close my eyes.
I'm gonna close my eyes...
And you guys say...
Say...
Me!
If you want to be...
The name of...
If you want to be Matar's husband to eat...
And then I'll create you a really cool...
Cool...
Avatar.
And...
I'm just gonna open my eyes...
And pick the first person I see, okay?
So...
You know.
Just say...
Me!
What about wives?
Is she interested in eating a wife?
Maybe.
Anybody can join in.
But you're gonna technically be a husband.
Because I don't think...
I don't know if she eats wives.
Okay.
I'm closing my eyes!
I'll give you a countdown.
From five.
Five!
Hold on.
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
I saw...
Nyanthony!
I don't think...
I don't feel like I should entertain this.
But a deal's a deal.
Nyanthony!
Where are you?
Where are you, Nyanthony?
Nyanthony, where are you?
Nyanthony.
How do you feel?
I can't...
To be...
You guys, I'll even...
Oh, hi!
There you are!
I...
I even...
I put my finger on my monitor.
Like, I pointed to the spot where I was going to look.
And...
Fate has such a funny way of working out, huh?
This feels like...
This feels really cruel.
Nyanthony, because you're a cat, I feel like you would be very neat.
You know?
And you'd be quite active and playful.
But not very nice.
And not very outgoing.
More active.
I think that's how you would be.
It's destiny.
Destiny.
Cats are neat?
Yes!
They're very neat.
Let's see what we got.
For MP...
For Matara Pregnant.
This one is so scary!
I don't like it!
Wow!
What are these?
Why are none of them normal?
Is this some...
The guy from Team Fortress?
Are these...
Are these not Team Fortress guys?
Why are none of them normal?
I can't find just a guy.
Is this really literally all we have?
Why are people like this?
Where is...
Oh my gosh!
Matara Pregnant?
What happened to Stop Getting Pregnant?
That's to you guys.
I don't care what Matara does.
Thanks for making me smile.
You're pretty good.
Thanks, guys.
Nyanthony is from TF2.
There are skins from Command and Conquer Renegade.
Do I not have skins from regular Joel?
Okay, we're finally at like some normal...
Some normalcy here.
Oh my gosh!
Alvis!
That's kind of exciting.
Like celebrity status.
Okay.
I'm going to close my eyes and I'm just going to click and we'll see what we get, okay?
Five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
Stop!
They match, actually.
Back one?
What?
No.
What did I miss?
Love, Matara.
This one looks like a skin suit.
Like they...
This one maybe matches more.
I don't know.
Nyanthony.
Nyanthony, Matara...
It's Revolver, Ocelot.
No!
Nyanthony...
Loves...
Not wearing a shirt.
And also...
Not giving a bleep.
Oh gosh.
This is so hard to type.
Sorry.
Nyanthony...
Is a cool...
Super chill guy.
And will also talk for hours about his tattoos.
Is that how you spell tattoo?
Tattoos.
Don't ask about them.
He's a yapper.
That's why they're made for each other.
Does he like Ace Combat 2?
May like Ace Combat...
But...
Hasn't tried it yet.
Definitely...
Finger guns.
Matara and Nyanthony.
They have a roommate by the way.
Alright.
Who wants to be the roommate?
The roommate might...
Either third wheel or...
There could be some drama.
Okay, I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm going to put my hand on the screen.
Just like I did before.
Okay, I'm closing my eyes.
5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
I saw it.
G the game.
Okay, you're going to be really freaky if that's what you go by then.
Okay, G the game.
Let's see.
G the game.
This guy kind of sucks.
No, no, I'm just kidding.
G the game, you're great.
Very outgoing.
Super duper active.
No, a little less active but definitely very playful.
And nice.
Yeah, he's nice.
The roommate from hell.
G the game.
Is one freak you don't want to mess with.
This guy will always be peeping through windows and listening through walls.
Me!
Pasta, I'm sorry.
He seems chill.
He is chill.
He be peeping.
Outgoing and playful with that outfit.
Lore goes crazy.
Almost wrote peeing there.
You saw nothing.
My brain works faster than my fingers.
He hates Ace Combat.
No, he's playful.
Basically, a real life Volgin.
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
Sounds like the beginning of one of your raunchy books.
If that were the case.
And also a billionaire.
Who owns a super successful company and is the CEO.
Perfect, perfect.
Oh my gosh.
We're finished creating our family.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Okay, but we have to...
You guys, we have to...
Are those the Goths?
Wait, this is a park.
I thought it was a house.
I was gonna be like, that's a nice place to move them into.
Save?
How do I save?
I don't think I can save in this mode, right?
I think you can only save when...
Save the family.
What do you mean?
I think they're saved.
I think I have to choose a house to save.
Congrats to the lucky guy.
I thought you were going to lay down, Brandon.
Yeah, I think you save after they move in, but we have to rebuild.
I'm sad.
Choose house, save Rosebud, choose new house.
Maybe we...
Maybe we can...
Maybe this is their forever home.
We can add on to it, right?
We can add on to it.
I can do this.
I'm a construction worker.
Get rid of all these nasty trees first.
It's just missing something.
Like a garden wall, okay?
Hear me out.
I think this is really nice looking.
I think it just...
Adds like...
Like, it looks so nice, actually.
I ignore the barbed wire.
Because it just kind of looks like it's like a garden.
This place is too small!
Okay, hold on.
I realized I forgot to expand the household.
Okay.
This is how it's going to work, okay?
This is how it's going to work.
Wait.
Can I demolish the wall?
There is a tool for that and I don't remember what it is.
Click and drag.
Shift to...
Control click and drag.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright, so basically they have to go through the microwave hallway.
Okay.
They have to go through the microwave hallway to get to the second portion of the house.
Oops.
There we go.
Okay.
It's just a really long hallway.
And then it opens up.
Huge.
Huge...
Area.
Ginormous area.
Like that.
Yeah!
And then this is the secret garden.
That I talked about before.
Sorry, I still have my cough.
Apparently, you can still have a dry cough for like...
For like a couple weeks after Bunkai-desu.
Secret garden!
Garden!
Let's get the walls down for a second.
Okay.
New home, new me.
Meandering mossy stone.
Actually, I said microwave hallway.
It's more like a zen hallway.
You know?
Please save.
Oh my gosh!
I just started!
I'll save.
Tara's house.
There!
Okay.
And then we'll add some artwork.
It's just filled with clowns.
Who's this?
Nevermind.
It's filled with ladies.
Oh my God.
Do you think it's too dark in here?
What's this one?
Oh,
we need our Jojo's painting.
Jojo Bizarre Adventure.
Why?
Why is it...
There we go.
What's this?
A replica model.
Get back the ladies.
They can really just kind of appreciate the human form in this hallway.
And don't forget our five tigers.
One, two, three, four, five.
Happy two years to a certain go white girl go gif.
One of only a dozen realist works by Kimi.
The painting's artist names are pretty funny.
An unconventional artist, she paints with her tail and unlike most artists of her day, she's a dog.
This particular piece speaks out against the oppression of dogs worldwide.
Dogs which are forced to endure uncomfortable and even worse, unfashionable restraint devices.
On one side, you see the human.
On the other side, you see the guinea pig at the end of the hallway just staring at you.
And you see the dog.
You think...
You think about your life choices.
One, who controls whom?
The dog or the human?
Oh yeah, I gotta do wallpaper, you guys.
I'm gonna do the wallpaper we did last time because I really did like this one.
Shift.
Perfect.
There also will be audio of... There will be a speaker blasting something at the end of the hallway.
Probably like...
I don't know what it is.
Probably like some sort of mantra.
Children laughing?
Victor, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
You should buy a teddy bear in case the freaky bear visits you.
There's a chance it will try to have a conversation...
Really?
OK.
I sent that super forever ago.
I'm sorry, pasta.
Wait, we need a teddy bear.
This one?
Or this one.
We'll do multiple.
Now the room opens up to the reflection of the man.
OK.
We need more...
What's this?
OK.
Footsteps.
Whose footsteps are these?
And carpet in the middle.
Hello, Minto.
Hello, Artemis.
Save.
Thank you.
I guess we'll save periodically.
Did that save?
Did that work?
Why is the audio coming and going?
It's kind of weird.
Dance floor!
OK, this is going to be a super party fun time room.
Oh wait, we need a phone.
What else do they have in here?
Our buffet, our everything!
I'm so bummed!
We lost...
We lost everything!
I'm so sad.
Dr. Hunter infected you with Minto cough.
No!
We can at least get this back.
An instant pond.
Fancy.
Bubble blower.
Campfire.
Extreme campfire.
This is extreme volleyball.
Wait, what did I just buy?
Our toilets, our everything.
I'm just so sad.
We lost so much.
OK, but only cool people can go in here.
Actually, will they be able to get past that?
A voodoo doll!
OK, hold on.
There's so much here.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
We gave them a TV.
A TV?
Wait, yes.
We gave them...
Where's the voodoo doll?
Is this a coffin?
Skeleton closet.
We gave them...
I'm getting lost in the sauce!
Where'd the voodoo doll go?
I want that.
Oh, here it is.
Wait, there we go.
We'll put it next to the computer.
I'm forgetting what we gave them.
Everything.
Your healing beam helped me get a little better.
I hope you can have lots of fun fires and disasters.
No!
No fires, no disasters.
This is a clean game.
Thank you for that, Kazupa.
Please, you just sent one the other day.
Please.
Oh,
our fireplace.
We do need that, though.
I was so excited about...
I was so excited about our last house.
You guys, I'm so sad.
I'm just so sad.
I'm so sad.
Will they both be able to fit?
They don't need light.
We don't need light in the bedroom.
The other...
The other bed is over here.
We can still make it island themed, I suppose.
We can still try.
It was just so cool before.
It was just...
Our hula girl.
We lost everything.
They had a TV.
Okay, so we had a TV.
Wait.
Yeah, TV and a fireplace.
Where is the fireplace at?
Decorative?
Lighting?
Appliances?
Do they even have a stove?
No.
Oh my gosh.
They don't have room.
See, our place was filled to the brim with exciting things.
Fireworks?
What does that mean?
Oh, it's in building.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
And they got their...
Where did they get their couch?
Nice.
We'll move David to the next to the TV.
Fancy chair.
Actually, I don't like that one.
This one.
Too close.
Fireplace's son.
He can go on the other side.
What about this one?
Small fireplace.
Actually, new place.
New us.
There is an outdoor fireplace.
Right.
It's kind of fancy.
It's kind of nice.
Oh, the jacuzzi.
They need the jacuzzi out here.
The hot tub.
Of love.
And screw this thing.
We're going to give them a dishwasher.
Wait.
Appliance.
They get a real dishwasher.
Save.
I'm saving.
What else can be outside?
In their secret garden.
It's literally a secret garden.
It's kind of intense.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe a flower.
A toilet.
That's disgusting.
But we can have...
Hold on.
We had one before.
What the heck is this?
Ejectment?
What does that mean?
Hold on.
There was one that I wanted to put out there.
It wasn't under here, was it?
No.
Where did the porta potty go?
That's a shower.
Hmm.
Curious.
Toilet in front of the other toilet.
There are double gold toilets, you guys.
Umbrella table.
What is this?
Smart counter?
Do they not have any more space for anything?
Maybe there.
That should work.
We can get rid of the trash can probably.
There we go.
Oh no!
Hand!
I need the hand.
What roof do they have?
No.
I liked...
What one did I have?
Oh, the pyramids.
That's right.
We need it super tall.
You should save.
I've been saving!
You guys, ok.
I've been saving.
It's ok.
There we go.
Alright.
You don't need to spam it every two seconds.
It's ok.
Taunting artist.
Thank you for the membership.
Please excuse our PTSD.
You're excused.
I get it.
I need some art.
Wall art.
The face of Deku.
Guys, I can't find the...
The port potty that we had before.
That's so weird.
I guess we'll do this one.
Oh, that's right.
This is our monument.
This is like sacred...
Sacred territory.
Like that.
It is an outdoor.
Outdoor.
Is it in here?
Plumbing.
Other?
What the heck is this?
Personal sta... Oh, I found it.
Will your Sims be able to afford to move in?
Oh, we can move them into a cheap house and then...
And then we can give them lots of money.
I'm not gonna cheat the whole way.
But I do want them to live here.
I think my game just crashed.
We're safe.
What did we miss out?
We missed out on...
Actually, let's do the simmer.
And we need our legacy toilet.
And we need to put a fence around it.
Viewing access only.
Thanks so much for everything.
I appreciate you for bringing so much joy and light to this world.
My wife and I really enjoyed your playthrough of Mii's Eye.
Thank you, Brian!
Oh my gosh.
Thanks for watching!
I appreciate it.
Safe.
OK!
PTSD justified.
Yeah, a little bit.
A little bit, you know.
Oh my gosh!
How could I forget a pool?
OK, get rid of this.
We need a pool.
We need a pool, everybody.
We'll put it right here.
It can be just a little bit of a pool.
There we go.
Oh wait.
Actually...
Undo.
Get rid of this bush.
And we'll put the entrance right here.
There we go!
We're making the most of all the space we have.
We have... we are literally just...
killing it with this.
OK, what else do you think we need?
What else do you think we need?
I wish I could click and drag this.
Genie lamp?
Is that under magic tricks?
Hold on, I'm making the outside pretty.
I'm making the outside pretty.
There we go.
Seems one had a recommended reading list.
Yeah, that's what someone said earlier.
Oh, windows.
Yeah, you're right.
Let's make it bigger.
D
That should be fine.
Right there.
That should be good.
Oh wait, that's kinda cool.
You can see into the garden.
Right?
You can see... wait, hold on.
You can see into the garden.
I like it.
Kinda sucks compared to our last one, guys.
I'm so sad.
And the game just crashed.
Maybe?
Oh, no it didn't.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, genie.
That's right.
Someone said a genie.
Is this a genie?
A newt?
A magical newt.
A spell book.
Put that in.
That's why we tell you to save.
I've been saving!
What's this?
Guided to cooking?
The face of Shakespeare?
I don't see genie.
We'll put a mirror there.
It's kinda freaky.
Kinda freaky.
We need a dining table.
Let's see.
Okay.
Place to eat.
Oh, dining table.
Here we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
And some chairs for the...
For the three of...
Oops.
Undo?
Where's the undo?
Where's the undo button?
Hello?
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Undo?
Sorry, you still have a cough.
It's okay.
It's been a little annoying, but...
I'll do you.
Okey dokey.
Let's see if they can move in.
Let's see if they can move... Oh wait.
I probably should get rid of this part.
I'm afraid...
I'm afraid that they won't be able to walk through.
You know?
Okay.
Okey dokey.
What's poppin'?
Cinderatlas!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Alright, we save.
We go back to the neighborhood.
And our family, Matara Khan, moves in...
Here.
We can't afford it.
That's fine.
They move in here.
They buy this house.
Okay, and then...
What is it?
We give them a lot of money.
How do
we...
Wow, he's got a back tattoo!
Oh my god.
I forgot I made them...
I didn't realize I made them both in their underwear.
Matara, open that package.
What was it?
Control...
Control-Shift-C, right?
Nice.
What?
What did I just do?
Look up spells.
You know what?
You...
No, hold on.
How do I change character?
Here we go.
I told you!
He likes to go through windows!
Squidward Tortellini!
Jump in.
Matara hates reading.
Jumping in this hole will save the house in its current condition.
What?
Okay, no.
Wait, hold on.
Control...
Control-Shift-C.
Rosebud.
How many times do I have to...
Oh my gosh, it only gives him a thousand.
Is there more than...
Is there more than the Rosebud?
Pause.
Rosebud.
What does Rosebud do?
Watch our money.
Oh, semicolon?
Oh, you can use...
Like this?
That didn't work.
Did I do it the opposite way?
Maybe.
Hold on, maybe it's this first.
Oh!
It worked!
Control-Shift-C.
It's so quiet.
I don't think Motherlode is in this game.
Yeah.
Um, Rosebud.
Rosebud.
Semicolon?
Can I copy and paste?
Oh, I can, okay.
Okay, copy.
Paste.
Nice.
Control-Shift-C.
Paste.
Nice.
Control-Shift-C.
We're gonna give them 200.
Okay.
Nice.
Save.
And, how do I make you move?
Nice.
That's G the game money.
Evict and move in again.
Okay.
Oh!
My game just crashed.
This is a little painful.
My goodness gracious.
Also, I'm gonna eat some of my burrito.
I hope you guys don't mind.
I'll be quiet.
Okay.
Evict.
Yep.
No.
Okay.
They have been evicted.
Here we go, guys.
Here.
Wait a second.
Are they not married?
Or, what's the issue?
Hmm.
Matara is already going to the PC.
What are these guys doing?
He's gonna go use the bathroom.
And this guy is also gonna go...
Uh oh.
They're gonna fight for the PC.
This guy is already using the bathroom.
Hmm.
They're admiring the hallway.
He's so excited.
Matara, you have to go faster.
I wanna see Matara dance.
And this guy...
He's gonna kiss her.
Oh yeah.
She's dancing with no music.
Keep dancing, Matara.
Keep dancing.
I wanna dance with somebody.
I wanna feel the heat with somebody.
Yeah.
I wanna dance with somebody.
With somebody to love me.
What happened?
Maybe go knock on that door.
What is this?
I'm so curious.
What's in there?
What the?
They're all entering the tank as a family.
What just happened?
Did we just get a skeleton maid?
Is this guy gonna flush?
Oh my god, I knew it.
Flush!
Alright guys, this is it.
Bonehilda.
Oh yeah, I thought it was a CH.
Oh my gosh!
Matara, say hi to this too.
Shake hands.
Shake hands with Bella.
Who the hell is whistling?
Oh my god.
What is it?
It's G the game.
Great.
Rename the maid to Minky?
I don't think you can rename though.
Anthony is living his best aquatic life.
Who the fuck is whistling?
Shut up!
Who is whistling?
The kid?
I don't have a kid.
Mmmmm.
They're Bessies.
We're gonna brag.
Come on G, the game you gonna be?
You gotta also compliment this guy.
Oh, he hates the maid.
Oh my god, what did she do to you?
What?
Why did she slap him?
Shake your fist at her.
What?
We hate Bella.
Why are you so pressed about my skeleton maid?
You say goodbye to her.
We are...get off my property.
Goodbye.
Be rubbed?
By who?
Spork?
What?
We have a cat!
We're like GG.
No game, sorry.
G the game.
No!
The cat loves us.
Bella sucked.
She was chosen.
Keep this cat.
Keep the cat.
I didn't know you could get cats in this game.
Oh my...
Oh my...Oh my god, the purr.
What is Matara up to?
I'm not quite sure.
She's serving lunch.
And our game just crashed.
I think.
She's serving.
Guys!
I don't know if anyone else has played the regular Sims, but for people that played the Sims 2...
Did it crash this much?
Before?
Before!
Yes.
Yumi's stream had it bad?
No way!
Oh no!
I didn't even move them in yet.
OK.
We can redo this.
We can...
Re-zero!
Why is this so hard?
OK.
Hold on.
First off, we got to get her with Nyanthony.
Kiss.
Give the kiss.
Kiss to Nyanthony.
Wait.
Compliment.
Say Nyanthony, I really like your tattoos.
Entertain with a juggle.
What am I hearing?
Something spooky.
This guy is looking up nasty things online, I think.
Find a job!
No more playing games!
OK, Matara.
It's time to use the voodoo doll on Nyanthony.
There's opening an education for playground monitor.
Oh gosh, I don't think G the game should be around children.
Look again!
G the game, it's not the job for you.
Medicine career.
Medical technician.
Take the job.
$200 a day.
Sorry, simoleons.
Right?
That's a simoleon.
Take the job.
Alright.
Don't sleep in, buddy.
Go, Matara.
Go.
Go wish ill will upon Nyanthony.
Use it.
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
He's laughing.
He is.
Sorry.
Every time I close out...
Every time I tab out, it does that thing where it's like...
I have to not be seen anymore.
OK.
What am I doing?
I think you were getting stabbed.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Matara.
Don't use the toilet.
Use the steam bath.
I'm so curious.
Wait!
What if Nyanthony gets in the hot tub?
Right?
Oh my gosh.
Go away.
Go away, Nancy.
OK.
Get in the steam bath.
What is he gonna do?
He's gonna use the toilet.
That's fine.
Oh yeah.
Nobody greet this guy.
They all suck.
What the hell?
Nyanthony!
OK, Matara.
Now you get into the... Join him.
Join him.
We're shipping them.
And then, gee, the game is gonna learn some spells.
Sorry, I'm gonna be saving every two seconds now, it seems.
OK, it saved, I think.
Oh my god!
What happened?
I wish he could riz the maid, you know?
OK, they're bonding.
Look, they're bonding.
They're bonding.
Uh oh, she has a better relationship with, gee, the game then.
Nyanthony.
OK, let's buy... What was it?
The magic wand we need.
Where the hell is that?
Magical Alakazam.
Spinning Wheel.
Spells.
Start this way.
No original.
I don't have a wand.
Oh, it comes for free in the package?
OK, cool.
Wait.
Go back!
Wait!
Not Matara.
Here.
Nya...G.
G, G, G, G, G.
Ubajaba?
Ubajaba!
They are so getting along.
Oh my gosh, they're almost back up to normal.
Perfect.
They're bonding over music.
Ubajaba!
Open that up, baby.
Open it up, baby.
Yeah!
Alright.
Where is our... What did we need again?
Add to Inventory.
What the hell is it?
Oh wait!
Add to Inventory.
Oh, Magic Wand!
Maybe Glorb?
Nice.
Alright, now go back.
To the spell.
OK, look up spells.
OK.
Perfect.
OK, perfect.
Everybody is comfy.
Everybody is happy.
OK, G.
G.
is going to go now.
Oh yes.
Alright, here he goes.
Here he goes.
He's...
OK, Toads.
Oh wow.
Mix these three ingredients to discover the hidden nature of this spell.
What is this?
What are these ingredients?
Oh, beeswax.
Beeswax.
Honey.
Pixie Dust.
Oh my gosh.
I thought we were just going to read.
This is actually so intensive.
Snake Venom!
Venom Snake!
I think we have to learn that one.
I think we have to learn this one.
We don't have anything.
OK, go vibrate.
These two are like killing it.
Look at this.
31.
28.
She doesn't care about Nyanthony as much as Nyanthony.
Nyanthony is falling head over heels though.
It costs money to use the bed?
Good thing he got a job.
You have to get naked to use the bed?
No way.
Using the bed crashes the game?
Guys, I don't know if this is playable.
How many hours do I have on this?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even look at the reviews.
Let's see.
Store.
The Sims.
The Sims Legacy Collection.
OK, the reviews are mixed.
Oh my gosh, this person is like... The constant crashes.
No way.
I don't want to keep playing.
Quick pivot to League of Legends.
You guys.
Welcome to EA Games.
I'm so sad.
Wait, that's not even a review for The Sims 1.
That's a review for The Sims 2.
Hold on.
The Sims Legacy Collection.
Mine is also mixed.
Oh my gosh.
I've never rated a product on Steam before, but I will tell you the game is very unstable.
It's hard to play sometimes.
If you are doing very simple play, you might be OK, but if you throw a house party, the game will probably crash.
If the robber comes and steals something, your computer will black screen.
What?
Oh my gosh.
The price is too high and it's not stable.
Small family works fine.
Throw a party, it gets laggy.
Go to town, crash.
May I interest you in Slay the Spire?
Guys, I'm sorry.
I didn't... I didn't...
I didn't know.
Time for Simlish Karaoke?
Can we do that?
How do I look up Simlish Karaoke?
Simlish Karaoke.
I don't know this song very well.
I don't know this part.
T-G-I-F...
F-T-G-I-F...
This doesn't sound...
Who's screaming?
I don't know this part.
We are...
The Quib.
Skibidi?
Kinda.
Yay!
I don't know what else to do.
I'm sorry, the game kept crashing, you guys!
Quick bellacho run to end on a positive note.
I
don't know what to do.
Sims 4, I didn't buy that one.
Or...
Did I buy that one?
I don't remember.
Sims...
Oh, I did buy it!
It came with the collection.
Can I recommend you Ghostbusters, a video game remastered on Steam since I heard you love Ghostbusters.
I don't like Ghostbusters.
Oh, it's free.
I have to install it.
You guys, it's 22 gigs.
It's 22 gigs, I have to install it.
If you want to come back to Sims 2, there's a source port available.
I don't want to have to look for a bunch of stuff.
It's fine.
Isn't this Sims 4?
I thought I saw that you need...
It's like a subscription thing now to play it, right?
Like it's free, but...
To play is a subscription.
Or to get stuff, I guess.
I'm so bummed.
I wanted to get the bear.
We couldn't even make it tonight.
I'm so bummed right now.
Don't worry, just Ruby Noob.
Oh, for packs, yes.
Base game is free, okay.
Lots of DLC though.
DLC are paid, but you can play the full...
Okay, okay, okay.
I see.
Maybe Sims 2?
We can try.
I have to install that also.
The Ghostbusters game that came out in mid-2000s is peak.
It's the true GB3.
Let's GB.
Ghostbuster.
Oh, oh, oh!
This is also a big game.
Okay, I'm downloading it.
It's installing it.
Sims 2 will probably crash a lot too?
Oh no, really?
Even more?
Oh my gosh, no way.
Oh wait, that's right.
I saw the reviews earlier.
I'm crazy.
Okay.
Pause.
Download.
Pilatro.
Why is it so small?
Without playing a pair.
Nah, let's do a new run.
I don't think I...
Actually, I think I just started this one.
So I'll do a new run.
I saw there were Christmas Simlish songs, but no Santa Nuru.
You've been playing off stream at all?
Just a little bit.
Not a lot at all.
Okay.
I have to remember how to play actually.
Oh, we can try and get a...
What is it?
A straight?
Sorry, I can't remember what the names are called.
Straight?
Yeah.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, let's...
Oh, good.
I had a flash.
Wait, is a flash better?
Oh no.
5 cards?
Oh, you're right.
Wait, 1, 2, 3, 4...
We can try for that.
Oh, I didn't have a check!
I completely forgot about that, guys!
So I just...
I was like, why didn't I get any points?
Oh my god.
I messed up already.
Guys, it's because I'm all flustered about stupid...
Okay, let's restart.
I'm all flustered about stupid...
Stupid Sims.
I'm sorry.
I'm all...
I'm all upsety spaghetti.
Look at Dave the Diver.
Dave the Diver.
No worries, gamer.
I'm all spaghetti.
With upsety spaghetti.
What should we try for here?
We can maybe try for the straight here.
2 pair.
We do have 2 pair.
That's true.
But a straight would be more, right?
30 by 4.
Pair is only 20 by 2.
Goodbye.
Get rid of you.
You can hold R key for fast reset.
Oh, thank you.
I didn't know.
Return of the jonkler.
Fine, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I would need...
1, 10, 9, 8, 7...
I would need 10 and a 9.
So if I did this 2...
If I did these 3...
Let's try it.
Wow.
I still have my pair.
Ants invaded my room and now I'm covered in ant bites.
Oh my gosh.
I also had ants recently in the maid cafe.
But it's kind of normal since like...
It's abandoned and stuff.
Fine.
The 2 pair.
Go!
2 pair!
Thank you.
No, I didn't leave food out.
They started coming from my windows.
But like, I have spiders and...
You know, cobwebs.
I just don't know why ants would wanna be in here.
I mean, it's an abandoned maid cafe.
Like...
You know?
2 pair!
This round loves 2 pair.
Yeah.
Hey, we made it, you know?
That's all that matters.
Get my money and go.
Banana.
Celestial packs always contain the planet card for your most played poker hand.
I don't have enough money.
Plus 15 multiplier.
1 and 6.
Hot dog.
Oh, thanks for the spooky.
Sorry about all the technical issues tonight.
If it makes you feel better, I'm still having a fun time.
Fight on, Minto.
Thanks, Marilyn.
I appreciate it.
I'm sorry, guys.
I did really, really wanna play The Sims.
Banana.
Okay, we can try a banana.
And then...
This is a straight, which I tried getting before.
Minto is meant to keep the ants away, though.
Trouble, right?
Just happy to be here.
Happier here, too.
Let's do a joker card.
We don't know what we want.
What kind of deck we want yet.
Times 3 multiplier of poker hand contains a diamond card.
Club card.
Oh, what?
Has to be all 4?
Add $1 of sell value to every joker and consumable card at the end of the round.
Flower bad.
That's hard to do, I feel.
EA Games has been broken for 20 plus years.
Not your fault.
I thought it would be different.
I saw so many people playing the ports...
And I didn't see anything bad about it.
So, it's my fault.
Well, I didn't do research, you know.
The present isn't bad.
I mean, we paid for it.
So, I'd like to grab something.
I guess we'll just...
Grab that.
For now.
Okay.
Okey-dokey.
Two pair.
We're happy as we can be...
Just to hang out with you.
Thank you!
Catch!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you!
Sims 2 is a bit playable than the Sims 1.
Oh, really?
I didn't have it downloaded, though.
It's okay.
We're already here.
Let's see...
We have 3 pair.
I wish 3 pair was a thing.
Two pair wins with the mold?
No way, really?
Let's try it.
It really did.
We didn't even have to do anything.
Craziness.
DNA, my beloved!
It worked!
It...
This...
The last try worked so well...
Until I got to like...
The millions.
It was like...
You need 7 million.
I couldn't get that high.
DNA is big.
It does say it's a rare card.
I have enough money.
Bye-bye-bye.
It was busted for a while.
Yeah, it really was.
I want this voucher.
But we're gonna lose it.
Because it's gonna switch, right?
After we beat the boss.
All club cards are debuffed.
We could duplicate our king.
But...
No clubbing tonight.
We might be able to...
1, 2, 3...
We might be able...If we can get a jack.
Run from Touhou!
Run from Touhou.
Thank you!
Look at the membership!
Mink!
Let's try and get a...
What's it called?
A straight.
I'm obsessed with straights.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe because they just seem feasible to get.
And they're like in the middle, you know?
Mink!
No!
Come on!
Jack!
Woah.
That's okay.
We can do two pair.
Two pair!
Full house.
Wait.
Wait, what's a full house?
I forget.
Full house.
Three of a kind!
Sorry.
We still wanted this.
It's okay.
Cash out.
Cash out or crash out.
Create a tarot card if hand is played with four dollars or less.
Uncommon jokers give 1.5 multiplier.
No biggie, still warming up.
Do I have any uncommon?
I only have one uncommon.
And it's not really...
Well, I guess we'd get another multiplier, right?
Cough.
Let's try it.
I like trying new ones.
Still don't know what kind of hand I want.
Let's do play.
Maybe if we did something similar to before...
Where we can get like an ace...
Ace heavy...
An ace heavy deck.
Then we can...
Maybe you guys can help me figure out what I did wrong before.
Maybe.
Hi Mint, am I permitted to ask about cat updates?
Of course!
My kitties are good!
I don't think you did anything wrong before.
Oh no, I meant like how I failed off stream.
Like what I should have done to be able to continue using what I had already created.
Minto is my ace.
Minto love.
Things are too much!
Why do you gotta use the yellow hearts?
What?
But yeah, butaro all better.
Yeah.
Paws had some issue with her eye.
But I got some eye cream and now she's all better.
She also had a bit of a cold, but not so...
Seems like she's all better with that too.
Butaro, he's still stinky.
He's still just a little stinky, terrible guy.
But he's good.
Does butaro still have the cone?
Nope.
No, he's not in the cone.
The surgery on his arm is all healed up.
And it's almost like...
It's almost like it was never there.
And he used to have...
Since they shaved his arms, he had chicken legs, but...
Now his hair is growing back, so his legs look less like chicken bone legs.
So yeah, that's why I haven't had so many updates, because...
There hasn't really been anything to update.
Stop!
Eleven!
You're so on brand.
What should we do here, guys?
Oh wait, right.
Maybe we try... I was going to say we try.
Oh wait, one, two, we got a queen.
And a ten.
Queen and a ten.
We can make it.
Fish for queen.
Let's do a flush.
Wait, flush is what?
Five cards that share the same suit.
One, two, three.
True!
Let's try for the flush instead.
I'm just going to throw these away, because if we get the queen and the ten, that would be good too.
Takisawa, thanks for the ten yen!
Get rid of these two.
Wait, one, two, three.
We'll get rid of these three.
We need ten or we need two more spades.
That's a spade, right?
Yeah.
One, two...
Wait, did I just... Did I get rid of a spade?
I thought I had three.
Yeah,
I know the straight.
Full house, we have that.
Three of a kind and a pair.
No, we could try.
Is that riskier than going with the straight, I wonder.
Full house, straight.
Because I would have to get rid of stuff, you know.
Yeah, I only have one discard.
Discard.
Full house is more likely.
Full house is the... Sorry, I'm constantly having to check.
Three of a kind and a pair, so if we try for a king...
If we try for a king...
Oh wait, no, no, no.
That's a pair.
We did it!
Nice!
Did sims break?
Unfortunately, yes.
Yes, unfortunately the sims broke.
Nice!
Let's go guys, let's go.
What's the vows?
Oh, the re-roll.
One free re-roll.
Level up straight flush.
One of three playing cards.
I'm gonna save money.
Skippa skippa, yeah, I was gonna say, I'm gonna say, I don't...
I thought about...
Adding some new cards or trying to get some special cards, but...
YouTube AI said this is Uno.
I'm just gonna get rid of these for now, I suppose.
It is Uno, yeah.
Three of a... Wait, three is a flush?
Wait, no, full house.
Three and a pair.
We need the pair.
What do I try the pair?
It could be anything.
Maybe...
Maybe the ace, since I've been...
Since I have been...
Copying it.
I have more aces, you know?
So let's get king.
Alright, discard.
Play!
Megamon.
That's the Bellatrio mindset.
Let's see.
More aces, true.
True.
Wait, can I use it?
How do I use it?
You use while playing.
Buy it?
Buy it, sell it later?
Okay.
Negative one hand size.
Play.
Suit.
Oh sorry, rank.
Yeah, we do have two pairs.
Wait, does that count though?
Is it only one pair or is it two pairs?
Does two pair count?
Let's see.
It does.
We can do a full house.
Should we go for the king?
Move Joker to the right?
Okay.
Or baseball?
Joker order.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
Use a tarot.
Wait...
It's two cards.
We could get four of a kind.
We can do these two.
We'll do these two.
Yeah, we'll use...
1, 2, 3, 4, baby, play!
Ta-da!
Nice.
Plus one discard each round.
Permanently gain one hand per round.
Voucher is big.
I like this one, yeah.
Grabber.
Grabby grab.
I...
I wish you could hold.
I wish you could hold certain jokers.
More discards is good for fishing.
I know!
That's why I'm like... But we just got a bigger hand, so...
The gift is causing your cards to get better and... Wow!
Nice.
Yeah, we got eight dollars on these.
Seven dollars.
Save for now.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
We'll save for now.
Okay.
Let's go in, baby.
Oh, nicer.
Actually, this is not so bad.
Play.
We could even do the...
The full house.
We could do the full house.
Let's try it.
Discard?
Then we got the two pair.
How much is that?
Plus eight multiplier?
Let's try it.
I think that should be enough.
That was not enough.
What did I do?
That was one pair.
You played a king, queen?
Oopsie.
Hmm...
We almost have a straight.
Let's see if... Actually, wait.
If I get one more, we can do the...
The flush.
So, one, two, three, four.
Let's get rid of these.
One, two, three, four, five!
There we go.
Nice.
She had a straight.
Yeah, but flush is better than a straight.
So, take that.
Flush is better than a straight.
What's this guy?
First played face card gives x2 multiplier when scored.
Increases the rank of up to two cards selected by...
Oh, wait.
Creates the last tarot or play a card you use during this round.
I don't get it.
Photo Chad.
Wait, we are correcting Chad?
I might be a genius.
It's a cop...
The fool's tarot copies.
It's a copier of your last planet card.
Oh, which I...
I have not... I don't have that.
But I could buy it and just have it.
Wait, first... So, wait, is this one good?
The first played face card gives x2 multiplier when scored.
I mean, it doesn't seem bad.
That's what it would copy.
Oh, it would just copy this one?
That would be so funny.
Oh, it would copy the strength.
Oh, yeah, it does say tarot or planet card.
I know how to read.
We could hold on to it.
The strength is not bad.
Because if we use it in the situation we did before, you know...
Let's just hold on to it for now.
I love copying.
If we get a jack, we can have a...
That's right.
4, 1, 2, 3.
Or we can get a...
Jolly joker 5 left, Minto, please.
Oh, sorry.
I already left.
Tarot perfect here.
But...
But what would I...
Maybe I could try to get 2 queens?
Or I mean, I could try and get more aces.
To get like a 4 of a kind or something, you know?
Fish for a jack.
I think I need to stop doing straights so much though, because I...
Well, unless I level it up, but...
Look!
Look, we've done 3 full houses...
And 0 straights, even though I keep trying to get straights.
You know?
I feel like I'm wanting to do straights, but...
I'm finding that doing the higher ones are even easier to get with my deck.
You know?
Just joined.
Did the Sims not work?
Unfortunately, no.
Straights can be really finicky.
Sims 2 turned 21 this year.
This year, the Sims 2 can officially drink.
Wow.
It'll finally drink itself to sleep.
Since it's unplayable!
It's a full house run.
Let's try...
Okay, you know what?
Use...
It becomes the strength...
And then...
Use...
Okay...
And then...
I'm gonna go with the queen.
We do have a pair.
I'm just gonna play these.
I'm just gonna play them.
We did it.
No, no, no, no.
Yippee!
Oh,
it's the castle!
And then...
I played cards with odd rank.
Give plus 31.
Chipsman scored.
Aces are odd.
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
But 31 chips doesn't feel very high.
Is it that good?
I'm trusting you guys.
Lose $1 per card played.
I'm gonna have no money!
Wait.
I'm actually gonna have no money.
My money!
I'm getting rid of like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I'm getting rid of like everything right here.
Actually...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
I have a...
I have a flush!
Sorry.
That one struggled against me.
Am I gonna go into the negatives?
Is that even possible?
No.
It is possible.
Oh gosh.
Wait, this isn't The Sims.
No!
Stop rubbing it in my face!
I'm gonna get rid of...
these 4.
5.
Dang it.
But...
What is it?
4 of a kind.
Sorry.
I know I'm always looking.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
4, 3, 4.
Go for 5 of a kind.
It's okay.
We still won.
We didn't go into the negatives!
Yippee!
Tarot cards appear to the... Okay, nevermind.
So does it increase?
Go up to 20... Oh, I guess you can go into the negatives.
It does go up.
So...
I think we can sell...
What's this one?
Uncommon jokers.
How many uncommons do I got?
Only one.
Sell Jolly Joker?
I don't... I think I can get rid of this one, actually.
I know this game was intimidating for you at first, but you're a natural, for real!
Hope this makes up for the dollars the tooth stole.
Keep bonking those Jonkler streamers.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the first hour!
It's super tiny, even.
Is it legitimate?
Thank you.
That one makes the other sell better, which means Jolly is high.
Jolly is only $5.
Yeah, he'd be our uncommon, so if I...
Oh, wait, you're right.
So if I unsold...
Okay.
I guess...
Yeah, okay.
I understand.
Okay.
Doesn't matter where I put him.
Here.
I think.
Odd to left, baseball to right.
Okay.
Next round.
Gift needs to be left, too?
Does it?
Gift should be right?
Wait, why are you...
People are telling me two opposite things.
Gift doesn't matter where it is.
Yeah, I didn't think so, right?
Because it's only just giving us a dollar.
Doesn't really matter.
Okay.
We almost have a strike!
But we also almost have a flash.
We also almost have a strike... Wait.
Here.
Let's try and get a jack.
We did it.
Mentioned Henya is the cutest VTuber.
I agree, Henya is the cutest VTuber.
It's my Kamiyoshi there.
You're looking for your most popular hand.
But I... It's my most popular, but...
But... But... But...
I have no multiplier.
I have no levels up on anything.
I have no levels up.
Two pair.
Two pair is more popular.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
I didn't even notice.
Two pair.
High card.
Oh yeah, because I play the ace all the time.
I was like, what?
Why is that so high?
I'm gonna go for...
Full house.
I'm
gonna go for full house.
With the queens.
And how easy...
Wait, what if I do four of a kind?
That's even more.
Just kidding.
Easy peasy.
Fish for five of a kind.
Oh, it's okay.
Nice.
One free reroll.
100 trips played if...
If it contains a straight.
It's the hand I always am looking for.
But the hand I never play.
I literally am always looking for straight.
But I never play it.
No straight here.
Not this red.
Okay, I'm gonna just go to the next room.
Now I'm fishing for the five of a kind.
Six of a kind?
You spoiled me.
Am I allowed to propose again?
No!
You are forbidden.
Ten thousand.
Holy moly.
Wow,
we got so much money.
What?
Three of a kind.
A flush.
It's the same suit.
I kinda like what I have right now.
Oh my gosh, I almost click sell.
Pop the buffoon?
No!
Voucher might be a good idea.
I think I'm...
But I will...
The next is the boss round.
Okay, I guess I'll get it.
We'll get it.
The wheel.
One in seven cars get drawn face down.
Actually...
Okay.
Let's go for it, baby.
It could be a king, yeah.
I'm just gonna get rid of them.
That's an ace.
We can keep this one.
I think I'm...
The five of a kind...
The multiplier is so tempting.
Let's just fish for it.
It's fine.
We risk it.
We're risking it.
Aw, man.
I have two pairs.
Maybe full house?
Wait, what's a full house again?
Sorry, hold on.
Three of a kind and a pair.
No, this is definitely not an ace.
This is definitely... We don't know what this is.
It was...
It was in my last hand and it was not in the ace area.
This was in the previous hand.
Yeah, it's joker or lower.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't discard anything, so I guess I'll just...
We'll do the two pairs.
Yeah, see?
Or jack, I mean.
I think I said joker.
This is jack.
We're close.
What the heck?
I was not moving.
The game is possessed.
I'm not... My hand is not on the mouse.
The one of a kind...
Wait, play the one of a kind on the bottom right.
It's possessed.
My game is haunted.
Okay.
I don't like this.
I still have plenty of hands.
Well, I say plenty.
I don't wanna...
Playing the aces pair will win?
Really?
Just this?
Alone?
You're right!
Our multiplier is too strong.
Let's go.
What's this at?
Plus ten multiplier.
Oh, that's the holographic.
I wanna know what it's at though.
Run info shows.
Like this number?
18, 20...
25, 29...
31.
Wait.
Yeah.
Oh, it doesn't add up.
It's per hand.
Oh, so if I play the high card, I'll get a ten multiplier.
If I play two pair, I get eight multiplier.
I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Converts up to three selected cards to diamonds.
I wish I could get some planet.
Some planet so we can level up our thing.
The Arcana pack.
Yeah, we can try the Arcana.
Let's see.
Creates the last...
This one again.
Converts up to three selected cards to spades.
Creates up to two random planet cards.
Enhances two selected cards to bonus cards.
That'd be good for...
For these, right?
Enhances two to lucky cards.
What's a lucky card?
1 in 5 chance for a plus 20?
Left to take a nap and came back to cards.
Good job, I know you're doing great.
Thanks, Layla.
Lucky is good, maybe.
Bonus would be safer.
Just gonna say thank you for keeping me entertained while I do my evening workout routines to slim down.
I lost 17...
17 pounds in a month.
I planned on buying a treadmill to keep up my 10k steps a day routine.
Earthworm!
Congratulations, you got this!
You got this.
I don't think I've tried lucky before, so I kind of want to use it.
Let's test our luck, baby, baby!
11,000.
Is this Bellatrio?
It is.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Discard.
This is the flush.
No, this is the full house.
Let's raise our multiplier.
There's her straight!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
Oh my god!
Where did the Sims go?
Ask EA!
Why they can't do a decent pour?
Why the game is always crashing?
Wait, 7?
I can't do 7 straight.
But look at that!
That is kind of crazy.
I'm just going to play it.
Okay.
Another!
Another full house!
EA being EA.
Unfortunately.
I'm still a little bummed about it.
Because I really did want to play the Sims.
I was so excited.
Ah...
Yay!
Okay.
The devil card.
Enhances one selected card into a gold card.
With the gold... Oh, 3 dollars if the card is held in the hand at the end of the round.
What's this one?
Sorry, I'm putting on hand lotion.
Oh, this one.
Double Arcana pack sounds fun.
We could do both.
We could.
Boss re-roll is huge, but it's 10 dollars per roll.
It's expensive.
Probably has free 20 dollars.
It could be worth it.
Okay, I'll get it.
Sorry, I wanted to at least do one Arcana.
Oh, we are not at the boss yet.
Okay, that's fine.
I thought we were at the boss.
Okay.
We have three.
One, two...
Okay, goodbye.
I love being able to play face cards.
Full house.
I'm going for... Oh, wait.
I'm going for more aces.
Ouch.
Play the five dead cards?
You're right.
We'll at least get the multiplier on it.
Let's see.
20 multiplier!
Nice.
We got a Celestial pack!
This one is plus eight.
Oh, the pair.
This Joker can...
This Joker gains plus two multiplier if the...
Two pair.
Pants.
Do you think it's finally time to sell the gift?
And we get the pants?
Because then we would get the uncommon.
We would get another uncommon bonus.
Oh, but wait.
This is our only uncommon bonus.
I think maybe Odd Todd might be good.
I don't know.
I think we might want to sell Odd Todd.
And then we'll get the two bonus.
The pants are funny.
Hold on.
I'm going to make a message.
I'm going to write a thing.
The Sims kept crashing, so now we bilateral.
There we go.
Now everybody can stop asking.
First of all I want to open this.
Four of a kind?
Strange.
Full house.
We do full house quite a bit.
Full house is good.
Either would be good.
Four of a kind or full house.
I think we should go for the four of a kind though.
I wish I could have done two.
No.
Destroys up to two selected cards.
Enhances two selected to be lucky.
Oh, we can do more lucky cards.
We can do more lucky cards with the Wheel of Fortune.
Let's do the wheel!
Wheel of Fortune!
That's two for two baby.
Wait!
He was the one I was going to sell!
We can't sell Odd Todd now!
He's our lucky guy!
No!
Sell DNA?
I've been using it!
No buff.
It does actually have a buff because we have the Joker card.
Every uncommon gives us 1.5 multiplier.
So that's why I would want to sell Odd Todd because then we could get the other uncommon.
And it would make it even more of a multiplier.
I can't.
All face cards are... Oh!
Easy.
We got this.
Wait,
what did we get from it?
Okay, so we can do the... See I told you guys I should have done the full house as the multiplier.
I do full house all the time!
I think gift card triggers from baseball later if it's on the right?
Wait, what?
Gift on far right.
Why?
I'm so confused.
Huh?
Baseball triggers the gift card.
What?
I'm so confused.
I don't understand at all.
Explain it to me like I'm a baby.
I'm so confused.
How does it make a difference?
What?
1.5 is on gift card.
Yeah.
So what?
You're in common have 1.5 times multiplier now.
Yeah, they did ever since we got baseball.
And everybody told me to put... Everybody said it didn't matter where the gift card went.
You want supernova to trigger first.
Okay.
We messed up.
Oh, okay.
No, I know that the baseball makes the gift card have a multiplier.
I just thought... Okay, hold on.
Let me explain where my brain is coming from so that you guys understand why I was confused.
So I thought that this didn't matter because I thought that this was what was triggering.
It was and it was like counting how many uncommons were in here.
And so that's why it's at the end because I thought that's what it would it would go the order of operations.
It would go boom, boom, boom down the line.
And then at the end, it would say, okay, I'm counting through here.
And now I'm going to apply the multiplier.
That's why I was just like, why did it doesn't matter where it goes?
Okay, Chad also thought that and was wrong.
Okay, and then you guys saw that it was not acting in that way.
And then that's when you guys told me to move it.
Okay, now we're all okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I get it.
I get it now.
Okay.
Okay, we're all we're all we're all caught up teamwork.
Yeah, we we we we did the we did the prop.
We did the problem solving.
We did it guys.
We didn't read it.
We did it.
I understand.
Let me see if I can try and explain it for people who are confused.
So this baseball card gives every uncommon card a 1.5 multiplier.
We only have one uncommon card.
What everyone thought is that it would go, okay, down the line.
And when it got to the end, it would apply that multiplier.
But so that's why, you know, that it would like go through all the cards and count.
But it was actually just already applying it as soon as we got here to the gift card.
And so by putting the gift card at the end, it will accumulate all this and then give the 1.5 multiplier here, which will in turn give us a better payout.
But but the gift card itself doesn't give any any incentive, I guess, is what you would call it.
And so that's why I was like, we can put it anywhere in here.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that's why we move it down here.
I hope I explain it.
Okay.
I hope I get it doesn't actually get it.
Did I explain it okay?
Did I try it?
Did I try to make it easy for everybody?
Okay, I'm going to do the actually I'm going to fish for more aces.
I know I could do the flesh, but since we got the four of a kind leveled up, let's get the four of a kind.
You got it.
You did a good job.
You got me brained.
Okay, can't make it simpler than that.
Okay.
Oh, play the nines and the twos.
True, we can just play this.
So true.
So true, we can just play it instead of discarding it.
Yeah, it's a decent hand.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh wait!
I meant the four of a kind.
No!
Wait!
I messed up.
But in the end, it still worked out.
Multipliers at the end maximizes the mult size.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
We still did okay.
No, I don't want that.
All cards and packs in the shop are 25% off.
Whoa, this one's crazy.
When small blind or big blind is selected, gain...
No, I don't want to destroy a joker.
That's scary.
Let's get the voucher.
Clearance sale!
Yeah, this one's scary.
This one's too scary.
We could ruin our entire build with this guy.
That's scary.
Sacrifice jokers.
No, that was scary.
Madness is good, but not now.
Okay, mod.
Let's get a jumble.
Converts to spades.
Stone card.
Gives the total sell value of all current jokers.
Free money!
Enhances one into a wild card.
This might actually be good.
We could get free money though.
There's a lot of money.
Damn, there's a lot of money!
You know what?
Why not?
I can play face cards, so why not?
There we go!
1, 2, 3, 4...
Let's see if we can get... What's it called?
The flush.
Let's see if we can get a flush.
I see.
So far, you're doing a really good job, Minto.
You're picking up the game faster than most people I've seen.
Really?
That's just because everybody's been helping, you know?
I think.
This is just because everybody's been helping me.
Actually...
You know what?
This works.
It's a full house.
Full house...
And game.
But you get it, get it, get it?
I get it, I think I get it.
But I feel more confident when I play with you guys, because you guys help me see things that I don't see.
Plus 4.
Oh, it's just a regular jonkler!
Wow.
Regular jonkler.
So that's still packs important.
4 of a kind.
High card is kind of big.
Oh my gosh, all three of these are good!
I think we gotta do the planet X.
Regular jonkler.
Just a normal guy with a normal life.
But there's something about him that no one knows yet.
Creates up to 2 random tarot cards.
Select 2 cards, convert the left card into the right card.
We could...
We could like make a random 2.
Or wait.
Left card into right card.
Enhances 2 cards to multiply... wait.
That's kind of big, is it not?
Enhances 2 selected cards into multiplier cards.
I think that would be even better.
Probably.
Convert up to 3 into diamonds.
Oh no!
Double money.
I think this one might be better for now.
The empress.
Crazy.
Nice.
4 of a kind, baby.
Leave the empress to my emperor.
What is your kingdom?
What is your kingdom, oven?
1, 2, 3.
Oh, we almost have a straight!
Wow, look how pretty the cards are.
We have 2 pairs.
I'll do the 2 pairs.
What is your economy like?
I'm going fishing.
Wait.
I thought this was a pair.
I'm going fishing.
Wait.
Hold on, I'm thinking.
I'm thinking if I want to play this or if I want to discard it.
I'll just play it.
We can get the... We can keep multiplying the runs, you know?
I think would be good.
Because we get more.
So basically the higher we get this, the more multiplier we get on it too.
So, if I can...
If I can play it, I will.
My kingdom?
Hopefully it can be our kingdom.
Stop!
Straight!
No, this is you, oven.
The jumbo buffoon pair.
Jumbo buffoon over here!
I'll open this in honor of you.
Let's see.
Play it.
Aces!
Give plus 20 chips, 4 times multiplier.
I think we got... Ok, Odd Todd.
Odd Todd, you've lived your life.
Sell this card to disable the current boss blind.
Interesting.
Sayonara, Odd Todd!
He was our lucky guy though.
Where would this go?
Like here?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
Far left.
Left of gift?
Yeah, yeah, right?
Yeah, this is fine then.
You know what?
I'm just gonna level up.
Buy and use.
Why not?
I don't ever use a straight, but if it ever happens, who knows?
Who knows?
And I'm even gonna buy more.
Oh, Dave the Diver.
I like it.
We're gonna put him in.
Get the hangman.
Destroys up to two selected cards.
I'm attached.
Reroll.
Banana!
One in a thousand chance!
This ultimate banana.
Uh-oh, it's the bus stop.
I'm not getting the bus.
Gone banana.
Wait, what would I get rid of though?
Time to sell the gift for this, but then I don't have this multiplier anymore.
I have no uncommon.
Should I not then sell the baseball card?
Instead of the gift card.
DNA?
No, no, no.
We're gonna keep DNA for now still.
I'm keeping DNA.
Sell baseball.
You can still sell the scholar.
I think this one is too good to have, honestly.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of...
I have so much money, I feel like I can sell the gift card.
I mean, I know I'm gonna spend money later, but like...
I wanna keep this one because I think this would be good if I find another uncommon and then we can get rid of one of these, you know?
So I think I'm gonna sell the gift card.
Well, it doesn't matter because baseball is useless right now, but that's okay.
Okay, discard two random cards per hand.
Scary.
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm gonna play it though.
Please don't get rid of my aces.
Play the four of a kind.
Nice.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
One, two, three, four, five.
Goodbye.
Two pairs.
Safe.
Minus one ante... Oh, it's this one.
No.
Jumbo.
Three of a kind.
No, no, no.
Two pair.
I think we gotta go with planet X again.
Let's just go.
Keep on multiplying.
Minky's so frugal.
I am, I'm sorry.
Goodbye.
Right now I've been doing more four of a kind, since I think that one technically gives us more than five of a kind.
Oh wait, no.
Actually, I've been leveling up the five of a kind.
I'm an idiot!
I'm so stupid!
I'm an idiot?
Nevermind, five of a kind is better.
Straight.
You know what, let's buy and use both of them.
Go for it.
I kinda pack.
Wild card.
Enhances one into a steel card!
Isn't steel the best, right?
We could get free money, but also...
Money is on sale.
Temperance for more money?
You guys, I have over a hundred dollars!
Steel ace!
Cause then I can start...
Doing that one.
What does re-trigger this card one time?
What does that mean?
I skip.
Reroll?
Okay.
Two random tarot cards.
Should we try it?
The two random.
Play again.
Okay.
Use it.
Let's go.
This one is so good too!
Oh my god.
Fortune!
My luck is all dried up.
My luck is all rotten dry.
Rotten dry!
I could technically get this one.
But I think it's okay.
But isn't there like a five of a kind?
Like a five flush or something crazy?
Reroll more?
It's getting expensive.
I don't have room for two planet cards.
I want this one though.
Flush five.
Just hold it?
Oh, okay.
Buy.
Okay.
Okay, that should be good.
But what if I get some planet cards?
What the?
Why did that one yell at me?
Can I
just buy this?
If I buy it, will it add the space in?
Sayonara face cards.
This is so dumb.
Oh my god.
No way.
Just don't play face cards.
Sayonara face cards.
No way.
I can't believe this is happening.
I mean...
This is getting really scary to my old build.
This is getting too scary.
No!
Wait.
It has no multiplier right now.
We'll start it later.
Later.
Actually, I probably should have tried to get a five of a kind.
You know what?
Whatever.
One,
two, three, four, five.
Wait.
Is this not a...
Oh, there's no seven.
Just kidding.
Wow.
Ace doko.
Is that right?
Put the... Oh, put this...
Here?
Flush.
No.
Oh, I do?
This is like...
I guess two pair.
And then I'm just gonna throw in the two.
This is so awkward.
Make a steal card.
Hold on!
There we go.
Now I will make a steal card.
Use.
There we go.
Okay, I'm gonna throw a bunch of things away.
Three, four, five.
Goodbye.
One, two, three, four, five!
That's a win, baby.
Oh, the steal cards need to be in your hand?
Oh wait.
No, I thought the steal cards were...
Oh.
Oopsie.
It's fine.
Every played card counts in scoring.
What does that mean?
One in two chance.
Okay.
Wait.
I can use this now, right?
Full house.
Okay.
Use.
Whatever.
Four of a kind.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's actually good.
Any of these cards are better than baseball.
Maybe.
Reroll.
Sayonara.
Joker, maybe.
Baseball.
Reroll!
Not worth, really.
But it's plus ten multiplier.
It's...
Okay.
What the?
Oh, scary.
Booster pack is skipped.
Glass card.
I don't like the glass card.
It's scary.
Doesn't fit your build, I guess.
Red isn't good this late.
Okay, reroll.
Adds double the rank of lowest rank card.
No.
Flush.
Was it flush?
Sorry, I checked.
Same suit.
I feel like flush does suit my thing, because I have a lot of aces that are...
I guess it doesn't...
I guess it's not the best, though.
Reroll!
Reroll one more time.
One more.
Oh.
Creates a random joker card.
No.
Sell the baseball and gamble?
Okay.
Why the hell not?
I love a good gamble.
Cards drawn face down after each hand played.
Scary.
Scary!
I want to play this.
But I think, actually, I will get rid of everything.
Wait, yeah, I think... I'm too afraid to pull cards face down.
I think I should fish instead.
I don't think it would be worth it.
1, 2, 3, 4...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I don't think it's worth it.
I think I should fish.
There we go!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
I'm still gonna fish.
I'm gonna fish for the steelies.
There we go!
A whole hand of aces!
Okay, we got at least one steelie.
Eight of a kind.
I know.
2, 3, 4, 5.
That should be good.
Almost a flush 5 too.
I know, right?
So close.
We didn't even have to worry about the face down.
We cashed out.
Planet cards.
Nice.
Mint woe is me.
I'm so cursed phantom.
What are you talking about?
Mega celestial pack.
Let's get it.
Pick two.
Pair, two pair, high card.
I still think that one is good.
Four of a kind and a high card.
Okay.
Perfect.
Nice.
That means four of a kind is a big money.
But still my five of a kind is stronger.
Four dollars of poker hand is three of a kind.
Two pair.
Bonus cards.
Destroys two selected cards.
More money.
I don't know which one to do.
Hangman.
I was thinking that too to kind of thin out the deck.
Because we have the bus stop, I feel we should get rid of these.
Get rid of our face cards.
Sayonara face cards.
And re-roll.
Plus one hand side.
Re-roll.
Create a tarot card if poker hand contains...
Wait.
Ace and a straight.
No.
Blueprint.
Wait, this one?
Copies ability of Joker to the right.
Blueprint is crazy.
So I guess we sell the golden Joker.
Bye bye golden Joker.
Wait, copy the banana.
I thought you... Sorry.
Compatible.
They are compatible.
Look at the way he is looking at that banana.
I decided to play alongside with you, Minky.
On a seated run.
Seated Minky.
For the Wisps that know this game, I have Bloodstone.
Oops.
All sixes, Blueprint and Showman with other Jokers.
I'm on ante-eleven.
Please.
What is this game?
I've seen it everywhere.
It's Bellatio.
OK.
So, to the right.
Wait.
Copy DNA for the first hand and move it.
Is that possible?
Wait.
How does that even work?
How does it even work?
So like this?
And then move it in between.
Oh my god.
Can move each hand.
Wait.
OK.
I'm going fishing.
Fishing.
Damn.
One, two, three, four.
Four of a kind is so good.
Holy cow.
Plus two chips.
Oh, blue Joker.
Hundred chips, evasion, tend to strike.
Converge three of the hearts.
Creates two random planets.
Let's do the planets.
Let's see Uranus.
Two pair.
Flush.
Boo.
It's good to have multipliers, I guess.
Re-roll.
Oh, high card.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, I think my chat froze.
Hold on.
One second, guys.
One second.
Akira, welcome back.
Thank you.
One second.
Hold on.
Testing.
I see you only on OBS.
Let me get you on my...
I can't read you through OBS as well.
Look at how small that Joker is.
Minto Joker.
What the heck is that?
Joker gains plus four chips if played hand has exactly four cards.
Okay.
I'm gonna re-roll one more time.
I don't wanna...
Nice.
Open the Joker pack?
But I like my guys.
What do you think about this game?
Would you recommend it?
Yeah, I like it.
What if it's a negative?
Okay, fair.
No negative.
Flush.
Three or fewer cards.
No.
Skip-a-skip-a.
I think we're good for...
This, right?
Okay, I thought we were on the boss.
Oh my gosh.
Forces one card to always be selected.
That one's gonna be...
Icky.
Nice.
Wait.
DNA.
Play.
Then, go fish!
Not enough.
Go fish.
One, two, three, four, five.
There are five of a kind.
Yeah.
This
is disgusting egregious amount of cash.
This is disgusting.
Tarot card.
I've never seen this one before.
I've never seen a legendary joker before.
What should I?
I don't have room.
DNA.
Is it time to get rid of DNA?
I think it might be time.
It's time to sell DNA.
Play.
It doesn't work for my hand.
No.
We got scammed.
The best soul but the wrong deck.
I mean, we could get rid of the boss.
We could get rid of the boss.
Honestly.
Keep the boss.
You have aces.
You have an ace filled deck.
Sell the legend.
The legend.
Okay.
Sayonara.
It hurts.
I've never gotten a legendary.
Hold on.
I'm going to open this real quick.
Okay.
Skip.
Plus one tarot.
Multi per tarot card.
Use this run.
Plus 15.
Plus 15 is alright.
Yeah.
It's not bad.
Not the worst.
We could get it for now.
I don't want to keep re-rolling.
Buy then re-roll?
Okay.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
We buy and then re-roll is a good idea.
Creates up to two random tarot cards.
Why not?
What the?
Two planets.
Okay.
These are good.
You know what?
Let's stick with it for now.
This actually has a higher...
This... Wait.
No.
I was thinking of this.
It does have a higher than the bus driver.
Alright.
Next round.
I forgot.
We're on the bus.
Do you think I'll be okay?
Force one card to always be selected?
Yeah.
You'll be good.
Nice.
Okay.
Let me do this.
Use... Wait.
No.
Wait.
Can I use this?
I can't.
Because the one card is always selected.
Oh shoot.
I don't want to use my lucky card.
Fish for aces.
Yeah.
I have to do this, I think.
I think I have to do the full house.
Let's do the full house.
Yes.
Keep going.
Like I said, my last... The last one I did.
Permanent again.
Oh.
Nice.
Thank you.
We went... Like I said, I died at the 7 million mark.
We gotta use this to be able to... Oh, I... Wait.
Yeah.
We can use this immediately.
Mars.
Pluto!
I think Mars is better.
We'll do the Mars.
Enhances one into a wild card.
Oh yeah.
Let's open this too.
Wait.
Can I use this?
I can!
Oh my god.
No way.
Big news.
Enhances two into bonus cards.
Is this money?
Free money!
Death is pretty good here.
Selected two... Ah!
True.
Do the king and steal?
I could, I mean... Steal the king?
Really?
Like him?
Turn the king into a lucky ace.
Oh, we could do that too!
We could do that too.
There's several things we could do here.
This doesn't look like the sims.
Ah!
Look at pinned message please!
Please read the pinned message.
Steal the king because you'll never play faces.
True.
That's so true.
That's so, so true.
And then, we can do...
Wait, what am I doing?
I... I...
I'm going to turn...
Wait, so turns the left card into the right card.
Nice.
Okay.
Since we did the steal, and now let's use this.
Straight...
The hand I never use.
Flush.
What's a flush again?
Five cards that share the same suit?
We can still get that, because...
But I think the four of a kind trumps it.
Or the five, if we had five of a kind, it would trump it.
But that's okay.
Enhances one into a wild card.
In fact, I'm going to buy this.
And re-roll.
A pair.
Why not?
We have money.
Re-roll.
That's why we re-roll.
Build your tarot.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, let's go.
Select.
In fact, let's turn this guy into a wild card.
There we go.
Four of a kind... Wait, our four of a kind is kind of insane right now.
Go fish, though.
We almost have five of a... We almost have a five flush.
Go fish.
I think I'm just going to play it.
It's okay.
Go fish again?
No, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay!
We win!
Greedy man.
Oh yeah.
Wait, I got a voucher.
I am greedy.
Greedy.
I am a little bit.
I'm going to buy.
I know it's just for a pair, but whatever.
You never know.
Arcana.
I think getting planets is like worth the money.
Select three into hearts.
Two to lucky cards.
Two to multi-card.
Glass cards are great for your five aces.
But they might break.
Make one card lucky.
Multi is better than lucky.
It's okay.
But one in four chance to destroy it, you guys.
Without DNA, glass is so scary.
If we had DNA, it would be great.
High priestess.
I'm going to do the priestess, I think.
I think trying to level up poker hands is important.
Emperor.
Creates up to two random tarot cards.
The emperor defeated the joker.
You're so right.
You're right, okay.
We get free money!
I'm going to hold off on the glass card.
I know you guys are like, get it, but I'm going to hold off.
Two cards to bonus cards.
Today is your lucky day.
Bonus!
This card.
One more.
I could do the four of a kind.
Like so.
I'm starting to get sleepy.
Oh my gosh, I just realized it's almost been four hours.
We're about to hit the boss, aren't we?
Yeah, let's do the boss and then we'll... No repeat hand types this round.
Okay.
Just one shot it.
Yeah, we'll just one shot it, actually.
Dang it, I don't have room.
One five of a kind wins anyway.
True.
I can't do judgment.
But I wanted to feed the fortune teller.
Judgment can make negatives.
That's two bucks.
I don't want to... It wouldn't kick out one of my jokers, right?
So if it creates a negative... If the very lucky chance it creates a negative, then we just get an extra card.
We need room.
Yeah, so...
You still need the space.
You can't use it unless you have space.
Oh, really?
Straight.
I'll never use a straight.
I'll never use straight.
But I will still buy.
I lost on the minky seed by gambling with the joker.
I posted a screenshot of my ranomito live.
Oh, go check it out.
It's a person.
Reboot!
This is scary.
Play face cards get 30...
Reboot.
You know what?
Sure.
Demon joker.
Creates the last tarot...
Planet card used...
Just buy...
And hold.
Buy and hold.
I'm gonna go in.
I'm going in!
1, 2, 3, 4...
We need one more.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Dang it.
I was trying for a steely.
Try for the steely!
Dang it.
Okay, nevermind.
I guess it doesn't really matter...
I'm gonna make these...
It doesn't really matter if they're...
Whatever they are, so use.
And then actually also...
Use...
Wait, what?
What is that?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then use.
There we go.
Okay.
Now... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
I'm such a genius!
But we don't get the multiplier.
We don't get the 5 of a kind multiplier.
Will we be okay?
Lower mult, yeah.
I guess we'll see.
Time to see!
We're okay.
Now we have to start getting the planet that...
Oh no, it's this voucher.
I have a question.
For the blank...
You have to get how many of them?
Is it in total?
Like, even if I were to die...
In the anti...
Across all runs.
Oh, I see.
Okay, so it's worth it.
In all your runs.
Okay.
Try looking up.
They got...
Pilatro Yuri on Tumblr.
Also, there's a...
Blue Storm Yuri mod.
What?
Excuse me?
No face card.
More lucky cards!
Feed.
Feed the fortune.
Converts up to 3 to the clubs.
Okay, that works.
Enhances 1 into steel.
That works.
I'm gonna jumbo.
Mumbo jumbo.
Skippa?
Skippa.
I don't wanna add any extras.
Flesh!
I think I'm gonna skippa.
Shady guy.
Poker hand has not been...
That doesn't really work for me, though.
I'll reroll one more time.
One more.
I guess that works.
Alright, next round.
Wait, I said I was gonna quit.
Okay, I'll do just this one.
500.
Holy moly.
I'm gonna enhance this into a steel.
Because then we can keep it.
We're not gonna play it.
Just one more.
And then...
To clubs.
It doesn't really...
I feel like I can just use this.
I feel like it doesn't really matter.
On anything, you know?
Just to feed the fortune teller.
I don't wanna keep switching all my aces around.
So I'm just gonna use it on these guys.
And then I'm going to throw them away.
Goodbye.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Our four of a kind is...
Insane.
Our four of a kind...
Is actually insane.
560k, though.
I know it's scary.
It's scary.
It's really scary.
No way.
So close.
We got it, though.
We're okay.
Gambling for real.
This is absolute overkill, but I don't care.
Absolute overkill, but I don't care.
Wait!
Flesh 5!
We have it!
We have it, the Flesh 5.
Nice.
Holy cow.
It's the most I've ever had.
Okay.
How do I save?
How do I leave the game?
If I just go to main menu, will it save what I just did?
If I go to main menu, are we good?
Black deck unlocked.
Joker unlocked!
We got the guy.
Nebula deck.
Start run with the telescope voucher.
Max out the earnings per...
Where is the cap on...
Isn't there like a secret card here?
Play a hand that contains Force.
Oh, interesting.
These are so specific.
Sadly, the Sims didn't work out today, but you made a really fun stream regardless, and I'm always happy about more Bellatro.
Thank you, Rob!
Yeah, I'm sorry, you guys, that Bellatro happened.
That the Sims didn't happen, but Bellatro happened.
I'll update the title.
And the thumbnail.
For half Sims, half Bellatro.
But I think it's Matara's fault.
I think it's Matara's fault that she was cursed.
And...
Yeah, that's about it.
I think she ruined my luck.
My computer.
My mental state.
But, also, go wish her a very happy birthday.
Is she still streaming?
Is she still going?
Oh, she is!
I wonder if I can raid her YouTube.
Let's try.
Oh, I can!
Okay, we'll raid Matara's birthday stream.
Everybody go wish Matara a very, very, very happy birthday.
So that she'll be happy, so that now that she's closer to death, we can make her happy so she'll have no regrets.
And then she can die and won't become a ghost and I'll never have to see her again.
We want her to have a happy, fulfilling life so that she doesn't become a ghost.
Okay, guys.
I'm sorry Matara did this to you.
I will never forgive her even if it's her birthday.
Matara's birthday wish was for you to play Bellatrio.
Otsumito, everybody!
Thank you, guys.
I will see you guys later.
Am I lagging a little?
Bye bye!
Itadakimasu!